the cma awards were the first 2020
awards show to have a very
small indoor audience for the show and
the show
insisted that they did it right uh by
telling
us we are following all protocols that
have been put in place by the cdc as
well as the creative unions to ensure
we provide the safest environment
possible prior
uh to even stepping onto our footprint
at mcc every single person including
artists and their reps were required to
be tested
with many testing repeatedly throughout
the week as
extra measures of precaution just as
with covet regulations at restaurants
all in attendance are required to wear a
mask at any time they leave their
assigned seat
staff and crew are also required to wear
ppe at all times
and of course practice social and
physical distancing tables are spaced
eight feet apart
and no more than four people seated per
table
yeah jay-z if you want to throw up that
uh picture again yeah so that's
how it looked inside so you got tables
in there people are distance but yeah so
one of the members of rascal flatts and
both the guys from
florida georgia line tested positive so
both those acts pulled out in the days
and hours leading up to the show
lady a pulled out the day of because
they had someone in their circle
test positive so here's mary morris and
others talking backstage
of being in that room but eight feet
apart
every artist in the room was like this
is very bizarre i mean we're so happy to
see each other and we can actually
you know have conversations like this in
the table
round but um yeah it was a weird
thing but i think um considering the
the circumstances they did an amazing
job the cmas did
and it really felt fun to just see
everybody again we were in a room
together
as country music
on this night live
and that's not happened this year so i
think that that was a win for country
music
and i think it was a win for where we're
gonna go in the next year or two just to
feel that sense of community and
and feel like we're kind of turning a
corner maybe a little bit on this thing
and
and making progress to figuring out how
to all be together
uh was incredible you know and to get to
play with my band was amazing and
and you know obviously getting to win
some awards is always incredible and
and not why we do this at all but
something i'm real thankful for
i mean it's definitely different but
it's really special that we
all get to at least be together and see
each other and experience
some sort of normalcy as far as bringing
country music to
fans and i think what's so cool is that
all of
so many of my heroes and all of these
artists are coming together as the
country music family and bringing a show
to you and that's really cool
the storm says looks like any restaurant
in america
we have really ccmas i know you're
performing on the rooftop so it was
outside but what was the protocol
like for that uh i mean the protocol for
that was
everyone got uh their temperature
taken uh everyone was socially distanced
everyone was wearing masks
other than the actual couple minutes
that we were performing
where we took our masks off they had the
microphones
um you know sanitized and
it was pretty it was a pretty clean
operation
i think the cmas because there were
people in the audience you obviously
have to have
more testing for the cmas but like
in this situation everyone was masked up
and there was no audience at all it was
literally just the required
crew and uh people who were you know
working the the cameras and sound
but it was it was an interesting
experience because there was no audience
uh you know like it was it was my as i
said it was my first time performing
the song you know it live but it also
had no audience so it wasn't like a
regular performance i'm sure some of the
just having an audience in general makes
a difference i guess as a as a performer
and so for them to be able to have
protocol in place such that they could
have an audience at the cmas
even though it was limited and socially
distanced which i think is obviously
great
it's a it's a good a good thing for
music and for live music
and for uh for country music
yeah i don't like people pointing
fingers i really don't i i don't like
that we're here
um this is not a sort of impromptu
concert where somebody decides to hit
the stage and put 10 000 people in
somewhere
that weren't tested this is the this is
the cma's and as a viewer
you just trust that they did everything
that they were supposed to do i don't
watch
america's got talent when they're firing
somebody out of a cannon
or when there's a trapeze artist who's
doing something that is terrifying
i don't watch it and say i need to see
your safety protocols for everything
that you did
you know i find it like i don't want to
do that with something like the cma
awards
if they presented a show where there's
people at tables and they're not wearing
masks i just want to watch the show
i don't want to be i don't want to them
to be forced to have to go through
their safety protocols they're
professionals this is what they do they
don't want to hurt anybody
i i really dislike that this sort of
attention is part of a show like this
because the show was incredible and i
really don't like that they now have to
justify
everything they did to make sure it was
safe
yeah yeah i mean in the same town
go ahead go ahead let's just say gg says
it was nice seeing and hearing our
country family
uh together like that everything you
just said roz
i do think i would have liked to see the
visual of people wearing masks in the
crowd like we talked about
a couple days ago the idea that
hollywood seems to kind of ignore like
they still have their parties they say
they're being tested
and then they get coveted and hide and
we hear about it months later i would
have liked to see
the visual of people wearing masks in
this time where you know there's such a
fight for people to be wearing masks i
know that they all went through these
these protocols i think just the
symbolic nature of
people in the crowd those people in
there wearing masks while they're
sitting there i would have liked to see
because it would have sent
a message to some people because there
are going to be some people that watch
that last night
and just assume those people just showed
up and sat in that room and sat eight
feet apart and you can't really tell how
far
people were apart so symbolically i
would have liked to
have seen people wearing masks i get the
idea of escapism we want like
you know just see these performers do
their thing but the people sitting in
the crowd because there wasn't that many
people it was
all basically artists right maybe like
their manager and stuff like that i
would have liked to see the symbolic
nature of the people when they're saying
they're wearing a mask yeah sorry go
ahead really
yeah i was just going to say i think
also we have to look at
our priorities a little bit when we're
talking about
situations that could potentially be
dangerous
because you know there are football
games in the nfl
that are happening every week and they
literally will have
7 500 to 12 000 people at all of these
games
and you know in college in the college
football world
notre dame beat clemson last weekend and
everyone in the stadium then stormed the
field
and it was like a thousand people
thousands of people
like on the field like partying and a
lot of them did not have
masks on and to me that
looks like a super spreader event you
know versus
versus the cmas where people are sitting
apart from each other and there's maybe
like 100 people there
in a pretty big room like i've seen a
lot of things
even with like uh some of the
you know election response in america on
both sides of things that aren't exactly
covet friendly uh you know
of people being out and about in the
streets and congregating and either
celebrating or protesting or whatever it
is
i just think the cmas is pretty low
on the pecking order of
danger
yeah april says the pointing fingers
thing ain't cool yeah he agrees with you
didn't watch the cmas
but they did a show where they used
safety guidelines and whatnot then why
should they put on a show yeah it was
great to see them all back again so that
worked